and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review prometheus
oh my god this is a greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life in space no one can
hear you spoilers there's a spaceship
called prometheus and the people on it
are like we think we found where the
beginning of life came from well I know
that when a man and a woman love each
other very very much yes but who created
that man and woman another man and woman
yes but who created that Magnum another
man and whooping chambers rates oh and
they're going to give the answers to why
they created us really of course not the
writers aren't strong or daring enough
to think up an answer to that so why are
we going back office hey so this is
Android named David and he's a good guy
working to help the crew or is he
actually even by the end we're not sure
hey genius the androids names are Ashe
Bishop : David ABCD Boise whoever
invented these robots is probably a
finger do himself I hope if they ever
tell the story of these things every
tome in this order so that amazing
coincidence can happen I think the next
Android should be Emilio Estevez oh wait
that's right the 90s cubed do they go
inside this alien ship and they're like
we the designer of this place must I
really like H R Giger
wait a minute H R Giger that means
there's a penis and or vagina monster
here so the geeky guy in the bully guy
who are obviously just there to die die
any Android is like dude it's a shame
we'll have better use some of their DNA
to create more alien creatures and
destroy the crew but why because my
motivation is vague oh and Charlize
Theron is also in the movie
I'm Charlize Theron's bye but then one
of the scientists gets an alien inside
of her and the scientist is like I need
this machine to perform an abortion
we're sorry
this machine is only designed for men
okay well let's do the procedure then
opens oh my stomach it takes a living
thing out of me okay man get that one
all the time
man she gives birth to a bouncing baby
squid from hell so she keeps in the room
where it won't get out but then she
discovers a horrifying secret the old
man who sent them on the mission is on
the ship by the week guy Pierceton aged
very well and he's there to see if alien
life-forms can save his life
oh nice also Charlize Theron's father
you're my father bye so the old guy goes
to the last of these alien life forms
who sort of looks like a muscle-bound
Voldemort and he's like hook a brother
up the alien takes a shape and plans to
go to earth to destroy it but then the
captain of the prometheus is like dude
and the black
in an alien movie we never make it out I
might as well sacrifice myself come home
till she miss destroyed and the only
ones left are the scientists and the
head of the Android tell me head of the
Android why do they want to cast I do
not know but the answer is lay out there
we're in sequels oh right and we're
disappointing resolution but it turns
out helia lacked in the room attack the
muscle-bound Voldemort
he gives birth to a bouncing baby he'll
spawn hell Wow this explains so much in
that nothing really directly connects to
the beginning of alien but don't worry
I'm sure they'll be sequels and Bill
droughts and cock tease the answers
probably as much as the Harry Potter
films did Harry Potter and the
prometheus do so I love Prometheus even
though did you meet him any answers but
he teaches a valuable lesson when going
to an alien world don't open up anything
that comes into martini shaker I have to
admit I wouldn't be able to make that
promise this is Jerry bum saying Jai
God shines I come on take a guy down
will ya good night James come on I'll
pay them to give her answers yeah if the
aliens are just Cthulhu sperm i D